I'm in like the biggest hill right now
usually I'm here fine it's fine I'm
cheating in my heels how are you young
Matt before this young man I think was
on the Cardinals yeah yeah yeah yeah
this guy's great so yeah don't just take
her word for it how does it feel to
receive one of the most coveted Sports
Awards that's pretty amazing it's been
incredible you know I think the biggest
thing is I'm more inspired than ever you
know a lot of motivation to want to do
more and you're doing amazing things I
love when people have such a big
spotlight especially sports figures
because a lot of little kids look up to
y'all and the fact that you use it for
such good it's like you're superheroes
it's really cool so it's awesome you
take pride in you think about it
positively but David what is the best
award you've ever won what do you think
Kelly I'm not really awards guy I think
it's just nice to be almost nominated
almost no I was up for a Golden Globe
and an Emmy Wow it went the wrong way at
the last minute when they announced it
but it's exciting no that's right
so Kleenex have you always had such a
giving spirit where did it come from I
started with my family you know growing
up my parents you know especially my dad
he really is installed it in us at a
young age that like you have to be
involved in community you know giving
back you know even if you don't having
like a lot to give back your time you
know wants to push cars out the other
snow and like you know go help my dad
maybe go out and help like their ladies
when your groceries are stuff raising a
job yeah you know and it really has paid
off because and I really am inspired and
I'm trying to do you know I like all you
can really control is your effort and
you know I don't know if I'll make a
difference in this world but I'm
definitely gonna try yeah and hey I'm
like a
Church kid so I mean even if you help
one person it's worth it you know and
you're helping way more than that but
even if it is just one you know that's
you're still super hero if you're
helping someone so tell us about your
CRC foundation I started with my family
you know some bunch of my brothers and
sisters seven siblings
Wow your mom okay mighty one we just
wanted to do something for my dad's
legacy and I got to NFL and I saw this
platform and just this ability to be
able to help so many people and so we
tried to just find different ways to
help so many kids and it really comes
down to you know just spending time you
know I tried I'm a church-going person
as well and you know like I try to say
that money give 10% of my time to
charity and giving back and making a
difference and that's hard to do
sometimes like timing is definitely
something that's special to me the best
kind of human I think is consistent and
that's the you know because the worst
kind I feel like is an inconsistent
human and I think especially when you
help with kids like that's the coolest
thing that you're still constantly kind
of appearing in their lives and not
going away so thank you for that but
what are some things the CRC foundation
does like how do they help well we do a
lot but I think the things that we
really try to focus on is really uh so
when I was younger I was in the seventh
grade and I really didn't enjoy reading
you know I read because I had to and
then I had a teacher challenged me and
like put a booger frame that I really
connected with me and then I started
reading all the time I love reading from
that point on so now my biggest goal is
to really just get kids involved in
reading soccer the reading programs and
just trying to find ways to make reading
more fun for but last season you created
this season of giving what is that about
because of this great job I have you
know you have a big platform and there
are a lot of charities that I like you
never know I wanted to really help bring
us exposure some awareness to some
charities that were really meant a lot
to me so I credit this you know you know
a season of giving you know I'm gonna
take you know a hundred thousand dollars
I want to give so I wouldn't look at my
stats the last five years and I've broke
it down also come with your 5,000 force
I'd give 10,000 for like a touchdown or
a big turnover
you know imma give a thousand for you
know for just one in the game and so my
goal was to give twenty thousand each
charity and I decided for different
charities any when I was in Denver I
broke it down to four charities from one
from because you planted in Denver which
is incredible we won the game and it was
it was awesome are you ever like if I do
that I'll leave that one there it's
amazing though it makes it fun to for
like the kids watching the families
watching I like oh my god that's two
grand right there people have to give
along with me too so it was like yeah
alright so clay is your foundation also
gives out scholarships I hear it's true
this is awesome cuz that's a huge thing
racking up all that debt for college
students that's really cool yeah I mean
I think that uh you know I want to
aspire people and help people like that
actually have potential to you know do
something with the lives and it really
started out like you know helping people
come from similar backgrounds me big
families you know financially stressful
you know and need help and so uh
different ways few scholarships in my
day
that's amazing cuz a lot of people give
up on that dream because they can't like
I couldn't have gone if I hadn't been
able to get financial help cuz the scene
like that's how I had to get
scholarships and some wasn't for sports
I wouldn't have been able to go to
college it there without scholarships
yeah you think you could have gotten a
sports scholarship there do what Kelly
I'm not on trial here I'm still baffled
you got a singing scholarship that's
someone I got yeah oh yeah first I sing
opera and so I got I could have but then
I ended up trying out for Idol so it
work with wash it all down the toilet
well my mom was not happy that I was
like so instead of taking advantage of
the scholarship I worked hard to earn
I'm gonna move in to LA and live on a
mattress and try be a singer and what
happened well my actually what's funny
is I worked here had such a hard time my
place burned down lived in my car for
today's drove back home auditioned for
Idol so yeah Wow
[Applause]
doesn't know this but we have a woman
here who says he completely changed the
course of her life forever seven years
ago she had almost given up on her
dreams to go to college she just didn't
think she could afford it that is until
she met coleus now not only is she a
college graduate she is researching ways
to cure HIV please welcome Deanna y'all
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
she's like move over um so
Deanna what stopped you from going to
college right after high school the
biggest thing that stopped me was
financials I was a middle child I was
pretty good at school I loved studying
the sciences but most people around me
either they tried to pursue higher
education didn't finish or they didn't
have the money in the first place so
they wouldn't even go so it kind of was
out of my range of possibility yeah and
happens to a lot of people all college
is expensive yes but how did you land
this scholarship like how did that
happen
fate stars aligned there in your favor
yeah a friend of my family introduced me
to his sister Keehan
and the moment I met her we like clicked
and we did a lot of things like we went
to Costco this one time bought a bunch
of food handed it out to the homeless
downtown that's cool he had a bunch of
charity events that we did all around
Arizona so one day her and Colitis
invited me to this fancy smashing
restaurant and I swear I walked in I was
the only kid all these people have 401ks
and families and I'm sitting there
sipping on apple juice in the corner and
I hear my name they're like dear Anna
come to the stage and I was just like
okay what's going on and they go you got
a scholarship to go to college and
culeros goes congratulations and I'm
like why you have no idea
oh no it might be because I was just a
child because I mean I feel like so many
people just need that opportunity and so
many people are surprised because you
can't you can't fly you know somebody's
cutting off your wings you don't have
the opportunity so I that's amazing so
how did the scholarship in college how
do you feel like that changed your life
for me College was the foundation for
Who I am as a person so I ended up going
to High Point University in High Point
North Carolina and I majored in biology
and the greatest thing was not worrying
about financials I was able to study
harder I was able to do outreach
volunteering music just expanding all of
my horizons because I had less things to
worry about so you know all those
research experiences eventually led me
to where I am now which I'm a senior
research support specialist at SUNY
Upstate Medical University
I love this story because look at what
we would have missed out on like she
just couldn't get in the building you
know what I'm saying and like we would
have missed that and you might end up
being one of the people to like really
change the trajectory of people's health
and lives and that's yeah it just drives
me insane how expensive colleges but
whatever it's a different show different
time with Deanna you have something you
wanted to say to class right yes go
ahead
thank you I know there's a lot of ways
that you can say that but honestly
without you and the generosity of your
family and you know the foundation I
would not have been able to be Who I am
today and the best thing I hope I can do
in the future is that you know I can
open the door that you open for me
for someone who can't even get close
enough to knock on that back you know
like I mean when you give back you just
hope that somebody's like listening or
somebody can take advantage of it and
like you just don't know you know when
you just try to do so much and then like
seeing like sitting here and hearing her
speak like this and just I mean this is
incredible it makes it all worth it
you're absolutely right too though
plenty of people are given opportunity
but not everybody takes advantage of it
and not everybody really runs with it
that is a shining example of your care
thank you and can I just comment on your
hair when you turn sideways I was like
Oh subscribe to my channel subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going